hi my name is Matt Grevers I'm Olympic
swimmer and my favorite movie is
gladiator I've seen gladiator apply 30
times maybe more watched it tons was one
of the first dvds I had the whole movie
was incredible I mean the story was
awesome the special effects church
flipping over the blood it all looked
really incredible I remember exactly
where I was when I first saw glider I
was on a train trip and I remember going
in the movie theater after a really hard
practice and I didn't really know what
to expect and I came out just so
motivated I just wanted to be a
gladiator transfer that energy of being
a glider into the pool so I was a
gladiator of the arena of swimming are
you not entertained are you not
entertained and just imagine myself you
know fighting tigers and other guys but
in the pool so in the water it's a very
peaceful environment you think but
really it's a fierce battle you're
against competitors all around you and
you're just trying to get to the wall
first they're splashing you're holding
your breath barely breathing and get a
little quick breath see what other
people are doing but it's a big powerful
race and you want to be killing everyone
and win movies help tremendously as a
Olympian there's a lot of pressure on
you there's a lot of anxiety that stacks
up from expectations so to completely
immerse yourself in a movie is
incredible because Nelson you forget
about your anxieties your fears you get
to completely be absorbed in someone
else's journey and it was a journey you
get to seen glad you're the entire
journey how he finally got to be able to
do his achieve his goal and and finally
be set free so when you win the race you
know you finally achieve your goal you
see your time you win you get to
accomplish what you've want to
accomplish hi my name is Matt Grevers
and I love movies and that's a wrap
you